Welcome back everyone,
it's Charlie. This is my full Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 breakdown and Easter eggs for the entire
movie there's a ton of references and a lot of
teasers for future Marvel movies like Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty Secret Wars there's so much stuff to
talk about so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're
also still doing that special Guardians of the
Galaxy giveaway all you have to do to enter that
is just be a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the movie on the video careful for
spoilers for the movie if you haven't seen it
yet because we'll be talking about everything but
the first major thing is that this is meant to be
James Gunn's final Marvel movie he was hired by
Warner Brothers last year famously becoming the
new Kevin feige of DC movies basically rebooting
all DC movies his first official movie as part of
that will be the new Superman Legacy movie I've
already done a bunch of separate videos about
that so I'll link those in the description below
because it's like a whole separate thing but just
because he's leaving doesn't mean this is the end
of the Guardians of the Galaxy team the team will
continue as they say during in the post credit
scenes there's a whole point at the end of the
movie is to let you know that the Guardians will
continue in future movies Disney already said that
they're not going to do fourth sequels for any
of the movie franchises anymore that don't have
Avengers in the titles of those movies so that's
why they'll do Avengers movies to the heat death
of the universe but like no more Thor Love and Thunders
nobody's getting a fourth movie for the most part
the next big place will see the Guardians team
though will be Avengers Kang Dynasty or Secret
Wars at least one of those movies it's also
the reason why they introduce so many big new
characters like Adam Warlock and Phyla-Vell the
female version of Quasar and by the end of the
movie literally says the legendary Star-Lord will
return because he will return in the next Avengers
movie that's one of the reasons why he ends the
movie on Earth where the other Avengers will be
the actual movie begins with a cold open scene
of Rocket's origin story it's pretty haunting
the high evolutionary reaches his hand into a
cage rocket has been living in with a batch of
his brothers and sister raccoons in likes him
to be the next in his batch 89 experiment his
89th attempt at creating the perfect life form
at the end of the movie things come full circle
when rocket goes to confront him and they wind
up rescuing all the caged animals rocket also
finally learns that he is in fact a raccoon
which he'd been denying this whole time now
he knew what raccoons were but I think part of
the idea is that he suppress the trauma of his
origin story so much that he just forgot that he
was a raccoon like he was evolved without seeing
the raccoon name written anywhere so he never
thought about himself as being a raccoon and if
it wasn't clear the cage that he sees at the end
of the movie with the other baby raccoons is meant
to be the exact same cage that high evolutionary
pulled him from at the beginning of the movie in
all the raccoons that are living here would
be his distant descendants now raccoons only
live for a couple years in Rocket Raccoon is
meant to be about 15 years old in the MCU so
these raccoons would be like his great grand
nieces and great-grand nephews but basically
all the baby raccoons that he rescues are related
to him distantly they play the Marvel intro scene
and there's another major change to the way
they do intros they give him a special intro
kind of like the Black Panther Chadwick Boseman
intro and the special Stan Lee intro during the
first Captain Marvel movie all the pictures
in the logo are all the Guardians characters
in different scenes from the previous Guardians
movies they also do not play the Marvel Fanfare
during the opening just because the tone
of the opening scene is so dark and serious
foreign
they start playing a stripped down version of
Creep by Radiohead as they go to nowhere and
show a long Montage of showing what the Guardians
of the Galaxy are doing right now in present day
and the scene follows Rocket's perspective as
he's walking past all the different Guardians
the major reason why they do this is because the
movie is largely from Rocket's perspective now it
is an ensemble all the different characters have
their own arcs Peter Quill obviously one of the
main characters of the Guardians but the way James
Gunn talks about it he says that rocket is written
to be the secret protagonist of all the Guardians
movies I think from the beginning rocket was my
entry into the Guardians in terms of creatively
you know when Marvel first came to me and they
talked to me about perhaps doing this movie I
wasn't certain I thought maybe it would come
off like Bugs Bunny in the middle of the Avengers
or something silly like that and as I was driving
home from the meeting I sat there and I said well
wait a second if there was a raccoon that was you
know talking and shooting people with machine guns
how how would it have come to be and I realized it
was just a saddest story that I could imagine and
that was for me the seeds of the entire franchise
that have you know driven all three movies and
the special and everything else they've done
even though the way that Marvel has marketed the
Guardians teams and all the Guardians movies they
make it seem like Peter Quill's Star-Lord is the
main character technically James Gunn is saying
that it's meant to be rocket has always been the
main character you also notice in this movie they
start with a moment on rocket and they end with
rocket becoming captain of the Guardians the sign
nebula is hanging up is based on the Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 Logo from the movie The Language
is written in Cree anytime you see these foreign
characters it's all over nowhere pretty much all
the languages that are written are written in Cree
because nowhere's head is increased space like
they've been living increased space this whole
time because that's near where xandar is where
the Nova Corps was a lot of people asking if there
was going to be an Easter egg for Nova in this
movie too just because they have such a connection
with the Nova core in the previous movies there
was a deleted scene during Infinity War where
they addressed what happened to the Nova Corps
being destroyed by Thanos before the events of the
movie it was basically like a 15-minute deleted
scene of him destroying the Nova Corps they were
supposed to set up the origin story for Nova he
was supposed to be a character during Infinity
war and end game but they just wound up being too
much stuff and they gave a lot of that plot to the
Captain Marvel character there's been talk about
doing a special presentation like a what-off movie
for Nova or a TV series we'll see what they wind
up doing with the character you notice rocket is
using Peter Quill's Zune setting up the twist at
the end of the movie where he gives him the Zune
along with leadership of the Guardians the lyrics
of the creep song are mostly a reference to rocket
in the way that he feels about himself like he
feels like he is a creep and the movie is largely
him coming to terms with his tragic backstory and
becoming less of a creep the lyrics are also a
reference to Peter Quill who's been acting like
a creep literally lately getting drunk all the
time his character Arc is similar to rockets and
he finally has to reckon with the death of his
mother his tragic backstory the loss of Gamora
and goes to spend time living on Earth he passes
Cosmo who's fighting crackling for something she
wants to chew on they kind of set the two of them
up in the movie as a pair like Drax and mantis who
become closer friends with each other than the
rest of the other Guardians like they're a pair
within the guardians but just as good friends I
couldn't read the label on Peter Quill's space
booze there might be an Easter egg there but the
super deep cut Easter egg for Rockets drink is
that he grabs milk out of the fridge the fridge
says milk in Cree outside apparently it's popular
enough drink on nowhere that they give space milk
its own fridge but the Easter egg is for the Bova
character because you talk about cows milk
she was also one of the first creations of the
high evolutionary in the comics who is the main
villain in the movie they reference her during
wand division because Bova helped Scarlet witch
in Quicksilver when they were babies and in the
comics there's a big connection between Scarlet
witch in high evolutionary they were born to Magna
in Magneto she fled to mount one degree which
was where the high evolutionaries base was on
Earth at the the time where Bova then helped
them briefly placing them in the foster care
of the maximobs which is why they don't have
Magneto's lyncher last name there are rumors
about Marvel having some Easter eggs for Magneto
being Scarlet Witch's father in their daughter
relationship during Deadpool 3 like an alternate
universe where we might see Ian McKellen's Magneto
become the father of Elizabeth Olsen Scarlet
Witch but we'll see Elizabeth Olsen has said in
real life that if she had a preference for which
version of Magneto would become her father it'd be
the Ian McKellen version not the younger Michael
Fassbender version of the character when Peter
Quill starts yelling at Rocket for stealing his
Zune he says that the raccoon twist later calling
him a raccoon rocket denying it but then later
finds out oh he was right the whole time I've
been a raccoon this whole time they explained that
he's been getting blackout drunk just because he's
so depressed over Gamora since the events of the
holiday special they don't say how long has passed
since the holiday special but I believe because
most MCU movies move in real time this way it's
been at least like five six months since the
holiday special and I believe this is meant to
be taking place in the year 2026 within the MCU
I think we're into 2026 at this point when you
see his apartment you notice the remains of his
wooden tape player from the Milano ship or above
his bed they salvaged it from the ship after it
was destroyed in the second movie on the title
card for nowhere it reads its the guardian's
headquarters so even though everyone kind of
goes their separate ways at the end of the movie
Rocket's Guardians team will still use nowhere
as its home base it's just that Peter Quill is
taking a break temporarily as our nebula Drax
mantis so they're still guardians but some of them
aren't on active duty they purchased nowhere from
The Collector after Avengers end game which
confirms that the collector survived Avengers
Infinity War we all kind of thought that Thanos
killed them the old-fashioned way not snapping
him but like literally just killing him with his
bare hands but apparently not rocket playing with
his zero gravity boots while he's talking to
nebula after this is also meant to foreshadow
how he defeats the high evolutionary at the end
of the movie High evolutionary uses his Telecom
make powers to fling him around the room rocket
just turns on his gravity boots to stop him from
doing that enabling him to start Landing shots on
him when they're explaining the Gamora problem if
you don't remember she's the version from 2014
that time traveled with Thanos during Avengers
end game she wasn't snapped by Iron Man with the
rest of thanos's forces they never explained why
but because she's from 2014 before the events
of the first Guardians movie happened she never
met Peter Quill or the other Guardians and had
none of that character Arc so she barely even
remembers who Peter Quill is which they joke about
during the movie like who are you again there's
a couple jokes about that during the movie like
the legendary Star-Lord joke which is a callback
to the first movie where nobody knew who he was
he wasn't that famous even though he referred to
himself as legendary Star-Lord who Star-Lord man
legendary Outlook the younger version of Gamora
is kind of like that new variant version of Loki
the reason why the TBA didn't prune Gamora after
end game is because whatever she did didn't create
a Nexus event in Nexus events are basically things
that happen that lead to the rise of alternate
timelines with dangerous variants of King so
even if you do something crazy with time travel if
it doesn't lead to a future evil version of Kang
like another Kang variant then they won't stop
you from doing whatever it is you're doing which
is why all the Avengers were allowed to do the
time travel heist in Avengers end game but now
because he who remains is dead all that's moot it
doesn't matter anymore they have a bunch of jokes
about somebody on the team taking one for the
team and just jerking Peter Quill off touching
him quote unquote in that way that always got
a big laugh in my theater both times I saw it
then we meet Adam Warlock for the first time
who arrives flying through the vacuum of space
without needing a breathing device which sets up
him saving Peter Quill at the end of the movie
without needing one just play plucking him out
of the vacuum of space the song he flies in on
is Crazy On You by heart because he does go crazy
on Rocket he's here because he's ordered though
by Aisha and tangentially the high evolutionary
to bring rocket back because High evolutionary
views him as his intellectual property and he's
obsessed with why he's so unique why he's the only
Creation in all of his many experiments who shown
any kind of ability a creative thought even though
High evolutionary has created much more powerful
Advanced beings like Adam Warlock in philavel the
other huge surprise of the movie is probably
the evolutionary created the entire Sovereign
race on a pure whim only for aesthetic purposes
like oh you know I wanted to create something
that looked cool but otherwise they serve no real
purpose for him which is why he so casually says
that he'll wipe their entire race if they prove to
be useless in obtaining rocket like I don't care
about any of you you just there so I'm gonna use
you but if you fail you're all dead so in the MCU
High evolutionary is the person who created Adam
Warlock he refers to him as the Warlock which Adam
Warlock does too I'm supposed to be the Warlock
mother I'm done listening to people it was Aisha
who gave him the Adam part of his name in the
comics it was someone on counter Earth but it
kind of goes that way too when he debuted in
the comics he was just called the Warlock it
wasn't till he came to counter Earth that someone
started calling him Adam Warlock there are a lot
of Easter eggs for his origin story in the comics
originally Adam Warlock was created by a race of
humans called The Enclave who just made him to
fight other superheroes on earth like The Avengers
he Rebels and chooses to explore the universe
and learn about morality on his own the funny
thing too is that he debuted in the Fantastic
Four Comics we're getting ready to see the MCU
version The Fantastic Four so we'll see if there's
any kind of crossover in the future between those
characters but his Arc in those original Comics
are similar to his Arc in the movie he's kind
of like Vision in that he's an ultra powerful
being who was born yesterday kind of like a
baby in a God's body who then leaves to sort of
discover morality on his own they mostly use him
for comedy in the movie more than they ever use
vision for comedy but in the comics he's more
of like a David Bowie Space Jesus kind of figure
like there's a lot more religiosity built into his
character especially with the counter Earth Arc
a lot of references to the biblical Adam and Eve
storyline eventually he meets High evolutionary
on counter Earth who forms a contract with him
to kill man Beast one of his Animal Human hybrid
Creations who's taken control of counter Earth and
upgrades him with the soul gem that's how he gets
it in the comics in the movie Adam Warlock has
a gem in his forehead but it's not the soul gem
obviously the reason he's after a rocket in the
movie why he tries to kill most of the Guardians
who get in his way is only because he thinks if
he doesn't get Rocket High evolutionary will kill
his mother Aisha in the rest of his entire race
so he has no actual feelings whatsoever about
the Guardians personally until Groot winds up
saving him before he attacks rocket for the
first time rocket looks at the key card that
he MacGyver together when he was younger to escape
evolutionary which he also winds up using at the
end of the movie to free his raccoon descendants
in the rest of the cage animals the way he pulls
it out of his holster it also seems like he's kept
that key card on him the same way ever since his
Escape we get to see some of nebulous upgrades in
action She's Gone full on Battle Angel nebula with
a pair of wings and Rocket actually gave her her
new arm that she's using which she can morph into
any type of tool or weapon that she needs we also
get to see some of groot's new powers too he has
a bunch of different powers during the movie as
his body has continued to evolve it's way stronger
just in general he can also continue to survive
with only a fraction of his body Adam Warlock
destroys pretty much everything but his head which
crab walks back to the Guardians later he can also
regrow his body relatively quickly he's got his
full body back within about an hour or so of the
movie he can grow wings which he can use to Glide
he can expand his body making himself appear huge
they're referring to that as like Kaiju form of
Groot and when Vin Diesel calls him Alpha Groot I
think that he's mostly referring to Gru's final
adult form in the post credit the scene where
he reaches his final boss form like the gigachad
version of Groot you also see later in the movie
too where he can extend a bunch of different limbs
all manipulating them like he has many many hands
all firing weapons but the other major reveal
about Groot was that he can actually talk with
normal sentences like speak normal regular full
sentences at the end of the movie he says I love
you guys earlier in the movie they had a bunch of
jokes where Gamora thought that they were all just
making up stuff that he said and pretended like
they could understand him but the whole reason
why they have to seek out High evolutionary
to save rocket is because of the kill switch
embedded inside him when he created him they have
to get the passcode to disable that Tech so they
can use regular healing devices on him which once
they get the password later and activate it means
that anytime in the future it's not going to be a
problem like rocket can just heal himself normally
using Med packs now going forward in Marvel
movies rocket has another flashback to when
he met Lila thiefs and floor for the first time
this is right after he gains the ability to speak
they also explained they had three different voice
actors for Rocket during his different ages which
is different from the way they do Groot even
when he was Baby Groot it was still Vin Diesel
they just modulated his voice a little bit so it
sounds higher or lower depending on how old Groot
is all of Rocket's friends are from the comics
they appear in Rocket Raccoon solo Comics is part
of his backstory but their origin in the comics
was a little bit different in the MCU they're
all creations of the high evolutionary but in the
comics rocket came from a place called half World
which was ruled by people called the game Masters
they had an Easter egg for that during the first
Guardians of the Galaxy movie in their prison
lineup I think the story in the MCU is that after
he escaped High evolutionary halfworld was where
he went next and lived for a time before he met
Groot and joined the Guardians speaking of which
another big surprise James Gunn revealed that the
main plot of this movie with Rocket's backstory
was originally supposed to be a rocketing group
spin-off movie that he developed way back when
they were first making the first Guardians of
the Galaxy movie They Don't Really explore groot's
origin during the this movie or any of the other
movies for that matter but original group from the
first movie met rocket after he'd been banished
by his people just like he did in the comics that
was their backstory in the comics which are called
Flora Colossus maybe some Future movie will cover
groot's origin story there's still another Elder
of the universe called The Gardener who in the
comics has a connection with the group character
maybe they'll use that character in the future to
tell groot's backstory the other major Easter egg
here with Rocket's childhood friends is that Lila
the otter was voiced by Linda Cardellini who also
plays Hawkeye's wife Laura Barton she's also
Agent 47 AKA Mockingbird of the MCU and in the
comics the other difference is that Lila was more
like Rocca's girlfriend in the movie she's more
like a very very close friend that he cared deeply
about they find out that Rocket's medical records
are held at orgo corpse headquarters which they
call the orthoscope or the orgo the place that
looks kind of like a giant Celestial butthole
orgo is a Marvel character but there's no comic
book connection to this version of the orgo Corp I
think James Gunn just created it brand new for the
movie the soldiers like Nathan Fillion's character
are called orgo sentries they also mostly use this
location for a lot of Comedy which is why I think
there's a lot of tongue-in-cheek jokes especially
with the way they visualize it when they head out
to save rocket their new uniforms are also based
on the ones they wore during the annihilation
comic book run which was the story where this
verse of the Guardians team came together for
the first time and they had a lot of elements
from that story in the movie like they base a
lot of the movie on that run like Adam Warlock
and Phyla-Vell  joined the Guardians team during
that story which they do at the end of this movie
they explained that in the MCU High evolutionary
uses legitimate business profits from his genetic
engineering experiments through orgocorp Science
and Tech they create through genetic research to
fund his illegal experiments in genetic tampering
which he does outside parts of space that people
are able to police so the idea is that he's super
powerful but he's not so powerful that he can do
whatever he wants to inside kri m Empire space or
as guardian space so you get the idea it does look
like a giant Celestial butthole but orgo scorp
sounds a lot like orthoscorp which is a device
used on eyes so you could say it resembles a giant
Celestial eyeball too but the real explanation is
that the entire place is bioengineered as are all
their weapons their Tech their armor essentially
it's just another research path that high
evolutionary pursued in his quest for Perfection
like why don't we experiment with Organic Tech
real good example of this is that all over the
base they have security cameras but the cameras
are organic so they're giant eyeballs instead
of cameras the other funny thing too is that the
armor that they're all wearing kind of seems like
ball sack skin like all the characters everything
about this place is just used for a comedy they
bring back the ravagers and Sylvester Stallone's
Starhawk character as well as his original
Guardians 3000 team from the comics yondu's
original team they explained that after yandu's
death and taser faces death in the second movie
Starhawk sees control the ravagers and Gamora has
basically been working for him as part of their
larger crew Peter Quill also says in the movie
that he's still kind of a ravager like I'm more
of a ravager than you are Gamora but the ravagers
are mostly a disparate group of teams that have
a loose affiliation and a leader who can tell
them what to do or bring them together when is
needed it's just that Peter Quill doesn't consider
himself an active member of the ravagers currently
the same way at the end of the movie some of the
Guardians aren't active members of the team like
we're taking a break for a little while the next
big Easter egg is for the Mainframe character also
part of that guardian's 3000 team from the second
movie in the comics in the Guardians of the Galaxy
2 she was voiced by Miley Cyrus but in this movie
they recast her with Tara Strong who's also the
voice of Miss minutes on the Loki series Krueger
is back from starhawks Team he's a sorcerer
just like Doctor Strange who would have the same
abilities he also trained to come our Taj at some
point in the past and then left that's why his
magical energy his portals are the exact same as
Dr strangers and Wong's there's a lot of different
magic users in the MCU but a lot of them practice
very different forms of magic wielding different
types of magical energy like Scarlet Witch uses
chaos magic which is red Loki's magic is green
Agatha the harkness's magic is purple dormammu's
dark magic is red Michael Rosenbaum comes back as
martinex they also change the special effects for
his face so that it looks a little bit more like
his real face we find that the blurp is also a
member of the ravager's crew to who winds up being
kind of like Adam warlock's new pet in a member
of Rocket's Guardians team you also probably
recognize a couple of their cameos Molly Quinn is
from The Castle TV show where she played Nathan
Fillion's daughter James Gunn actually introduced
her to her partner Elon Gale who produces the F
boy Island TV show does a lot of reality TV who is
also friends with separately who also has a cameo
as another ravager later in the movie Nathan
Fillion obviously also in this movie who James
Gunn has been friends with for a long time trying
to put him in all of his Guardians movies so the
other joke here is that James Gunn just puts a
lot of his friends and real life family members
in his movies they also have this running gag
between nebula and Gamora and their relationship
as sisters where they just communicate with each
other through Grunts and they just each understand
each other even though everybody else just sees
it as grunts like they totally get what they're
talking about rocket has another flashback to the
time he discovered how to fix High evolutionary's
problem with aggression his experiments and when
he writes the complex equation on the Blackboard
there's a real deep cut Easter egg here for James
Gunn's initial pitch for the first Guardians of
the Galaxy movie that he gave to Kevin feige he
said that when he was working on the first movie
very early on he sketched rocket doing this on a
Blackboard send it to Kevin feige sort of a proof
of concept art which they wound up turning into
one of the posters for Guardians of the Galaxy
3. when he says the music they're listening to is
from ancient Earth about 5000 years ago it'd have
to be from one of Earth's early cultures in real
life like ancient Sumerians he says he visited
Earth not too long ago they never State how old he
is but in the comics he was born a human on earth
originally in present day then he became obsessed
with reaching biological Perfection and kept
upgrading himself and experimenting on other life
forms like we see in the movie I think the idea
is that in the MCU this version of the character
Came From Another World and just visited Earth in
the past in the way he says that he got the idea
for counter Earth to make a more perfect version
of Earth is similar to the backstory in the comics
of counter Earth there was an Easter egg for him
during Guardians of the Galaxy 2 when they crash
land on the planet bur-hert that's meant to be
an anagram for Herbert Edgar Windham which is High
evolutionary's real name before he started calling
himself High evolutionary in the comics young
rocket sees counter Earth which is still under
construction at the time when he sees the rocket
it gives him the idea to name himself rocket later
when he tells rocket his experiments are halfway
there I think that's also a reference to Rocket's
origin story in the comics on half world the
experiment when he tests out his Evolution on a
turtle seems kind of like a Sly Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles reference and the other thing
going on here is that rocket solving his Evolution
problem is reveal feeling that rocket is actually
a genius and if it wasn't clear in previous
movies rocket created nebula's new arm as well so
even though they joke about rocket getting Winter
Soldiers armed during the holiday special like I'm
gonna get me that arm then nebula gets him that
arm by literally ripping it off a winter soldier
in the middle of the night James Gunn actually
talked about this he said that it's actually Canon
now like oh that's Canon rocket probably could
have created an arm just like that on his own
if he had access to vibrating him which he doesn't
because it's so rare in the universe now if James
Gunn says that that's Canon that he has his arm
now we'll see how they explained that during the
Thunderbolts movie when Winter Soldier comes back
but maybe Peter Quill took the arm back to him
when he came back to Earth at the end of the movie
when the Guardians finally jump onto the orgo
through space their spacesuits are meant to be a
reference to the space suits from the 2001 Space
Odyssey movie a lot of younger people who were
watching trailer videos thought it might be an
Among Us reference but James like no no not among
us it's 2001 reference the other reason straight
going on here too low level is that they're
all different colors of the Infinity Stones
but there's only five of them and there are six
Infinity Stones the song that plays while this is
happening is space hogs in the meantime the other
joke reference you could draw here is that one of
the characters in the movie is called War Pig
so there is literally a space hog in the movie
Adam Warlock winds up ripping his head right off
we meet Nathan Fillion's character leader of the
orgo sentries James Gunn has put him in all of
his Guardians of the Galaxy movies but some of
his roles wound up being really cool deleted
scenes in the first movie he played the alien
is a voice over actor who harassed Peter Quill in
the prison during Guardians 2 he played a version
of Wonder Man AKA Simon Williams the scene would
have been a movie festival based on his fake in
Universe movies that he had made all of which were
either references to other Marvel characters like
Iron Man or some references to Marvel comic book
characters like kodan the Barbarian and archon
and in some cases the movies were just parodies of
real life movies in the comics Wonder man's cover
identity is being a Hollywood actor when he's not
busy being a superhero they're making a Wonder Man
TV show for Disney plus right now they've cast
most of the actors they're going to be filming
pretty soon during Guardians 2 James Gunn wound
up just completely getting rid of the scene it's
just deleted the scene it would have happened in
the St Louis parts of the movie where the movie
goes to show ego The Living Planet sea growing
that's also where Peter cool is from St Louis
where ego met his mother St Louis is also where
James Gunn is from in real life his real-life
parents actually had a cameo scene during that
part of the movie there was also an Easter egg
for his parents during Guardians 3 as well too
at the end of the movie the actual end credits
are just scrolling through different pictures
taken from images in other Guardians movies
and other appearances and one of them is of his
parents Cameo scene the movie is also dedicated
to his father James Gunn senior who passed away in
2020 in the context of this movie Nathan filling
is just a regular security guard who hates the
men that worked for him because one of them's
an idiot which he references several times also
when he's making fun of Adam we're like oh you
got an idiot with you I got one of those too
there's a cameo scene from James Gunn's wife
in real life who plays one of the office workers
she also plays Amelia Harcourt in all of the DC
movies and has appeared in a bunch of crossovers
lately in the DC Universe like The Suicide Squad
movie Peacemaker Black Adam she just appeared
in the Shazam Fury of the Gods post-credits
scene Nathan Fillion was also in The Suicide
Squad movie as a character there was another DC
character in this too Daniela melchior who plays
rat catcher 2 during Suicide Squad also starred
as the office worker that Peter Quill tries to
seduce they have a real quick joke about a dude
whose head looks like a carrot that Gamora almost
kills he's not a character from Marvel Comics but
there is a non-marvel character whose head is
an actual carrot during the elevator ride Peter
Quill Recaps pretty much the entire events of the
Guardians of the Galaxy movies Avengers Infinity
War Avengers endgame he calls gamora's death the
magic Cliff saying that he doesn't understand how
time travel worked during Avengers end game in
references all the Infinity Stones her dad threw
off a magic cliff and she died and then I lost
my temper and nearly destroyed half the universe
and she came back out of the past there she is
everyone else who died in the past stayed dead not
her why was it the magic Cliff I don't know that's
some freaking infinity stone scientist Wayne says
he lost his temper and almost accidentally
destroyed half the universe that's a joke
about messing up with their fight against Thanos
allowing him to escape and snap the full Infinity
Gauntlet James Gunn actually talked about this
in real life he said that he hated that part of
infinity War Star-Lord botching things and claimed
that had he written Star Lord's part it wouldn't
have gone down like that he said that his version
of startled like as he writes the character
would have killed Gamora when she asked him to
preventing Thanos from getting the Soul Stone in
the first place which also a side note confirms
Jane's gun had no part in writing any of the
Guardian scenes during Infinity war or end game
and speaking of Infinity Stones and celestials
one thing the movie doesn't really get into that
much is whether or not the high evolutionary had
tried to use celestials or Celestial Tech to
obtain in the Infinity Stones in the past for
his experiments so I would assume yes he did
try or acquire some Celeste you'll take at some
point also because in the comics he had the Soul
Stone and gave it to Adam Warlock so there's a big
association with his character Infinity Stones
and celestials Rocket has another flashback to
the time he and his friends gave themselves names
floor because the rabbit was lying on the floor
thieves because the walrus had giant teeth Lila
doesn't say why she chooses that name but rocket
explains that he chose that name because of his
dream to use a rocket to take them away where they
could live a happy life together they start to
Face Off jokes to set up the end of the movie when
they had to count to Earth Face-Off is meant to be
a reference to a couple things their final fight
against High evolutionary his face actually coming
off literally they revealed that during Rocket's
initial Escape he clawed off his face completely
and afterwards he just attached it over his head
which is why it looks so weird like RoboCop's face
which Peter Quill references later also when he
calls him Skeletor that's another reference to
him not really having a face because Skeletor
doesn't have an actual face it's also meant to be
a reference to the Nicholas was cage John Travolta
Face-Off movie because that's literally the plot
of the movie them taking off and replacing their
actual faces Adam Warlock winds up picking up
blurp and taking him as a pet from the orgo after
he accidentally kills the ravager that he was
there with also James Gunn's wife I'm not sure
what her character's name is during the movie is
seen eating a carrot-like food which is a callback
to the joke about Gamora almost killing the carrot
head rocket has another flashback setting up his
Escape where he meets batch 90 who are meant
to be the animals that we meet later living on
counter Earth which the high evolutionary also
subsequently winds up destroying so press F to
pay respects to them in present day the Guardians
arrive on count to Earth and it's meant to be what
it basically is in the comics a perfect replica
of Earth but supposed to be better Frozen kind of
in the 1980s within this movie version you notice
he's replaced the Statue of Liberty with his own
likeness holding a monkey in the comics he started
out on Earth because he was a human then felt like
he hit the limit of what he could do there with
his experiments and create a counter Earth to be
a more perfect version of Earth where it could
continue that without the superheroes like The
Avengers getting in his way and just like in the
movie counter Earth of the comics winds up being
not perfect with homelessness drugs violent crime
and he decides to destroy it and try again in the
comics similar thing happens man Beast takes over
the planet and he upgrades Adam Warlock with the
Soul Stone and has him defeat man beast and get
rid of his problems to pacify the planet love all
the 80s jokes here too just the mizon send like
everything Frozen in the 1980s and all the jokes
that Drax has about trying to use the couch to
sleep on why doesn't have dual purposes why is
it shaped like this if we're not supposed to sleep
on it in both Peter Quill and nebula not totally
understanding how to work the 80s technology
car like how do you get in how do you press this
button and he doesn't know how to drive because he
left earth when he was eight years old so he never
actually learned how to drive a car like this we
meet philavel for the first time she becomes the
next Quasar in the comics that's what they're
teasing in this movie within the context of the
the MCU she's meant to be the latest evolution of
that particular race of children the same way that
Adam Warlock was the Apex version of The Sovereign
race all of her powers are similar to the powers
that she has in the comics she doesn't have the
quantum bands yet but at the end of the movie you
do see her giving off energy she does have that
ability before she gets the quantum bands in the
comics she's meant to be naturally very powerful
the quantum bands just make her Ultra Ultra
powerful they're meant to be kind of like Miss
Marvel's Cree Nega bands which they actually just
confirmed in the Marvel's trailer they revealed
that the cree bands from the comics phyllabel
is also from the Captain Marvel Comics she's
basically meant to be an artificial copy of genus
Vel the actual son of the original Captain Marvel
character their mother is meant to be an eternal
from the Planet Titan just like Thanos she's
the same type of Eternal so they're both super
powerful their children become Ultra powerful
as well when they arrive at high evolutionary
ship war Pig here is played by Judy Greer who
also plays ant-man's ex-wife a lot of dual role
happening in the MCU then they flash back to the
events of rockets escape the death of Lila all of
his friends him clawing off High evolutionary's
face and in present day he winds up inadvertently
killing Aisha when he detonates the entire planet
counter-earth Adam warlock's surrogate mother in
front of his eyes giving him the same tragic
origin story that Peter Quill had seeing his
mother die before his eyes it's meant to be the
event that sort of turns out on warlock towards
the guardian side but also on top of that is Groot
saving his life like why did you do that why were
you nice to me and that sort of turns him around
rocket winds up dying briefly before they're able
to fully heal him with the right codes and while
he's dead they sort of pull a Harry Potter Deathly
Hallows moment where in that movie while Harry
Potter is dead briefly he meets Dumbledore's
Spirit who gives him a call to action and Rocket
has a similar moment with Lila's Spirit who tells
him it's not his time yet the place that rocket is
speaking to Lila is sort of like a cosmic version
of the original place where they were kept in
cages when he winds up coming back to life he
proves the others on the comms he's still alive
they'll share a moment together which they use
for another Gamora and Groot talking joke where
she just says you're just making up what he's
saying right like it's all just nonsense setting
at the end of the movie where he actually does
speak a full sentence Peter Quill yells a bunch
of 80s pop culture references High evolutionary
making fun of him for his RoboCop face because the
way it stretched over his head He-Man The Masters
of the Universe Skeletor because he doesn't have
an actual face confirming that Peter Quill would
have watched Masters of the Universe the He-man
TV show cartoon back in the 80s purple nurple is
also just a prank where you twist people's nipples
till their skin turns purple because his costume
is purple when he calls for cracklin's help on
nowhere the other ravagers there are playing
cards Cosmo explains the rest of her origin story
which is pretty similar to the origin story in
the comics she's based on the Russian space dog
from real life called Laika who they tested their
early space rockets on in the MCU in 1966 the
Soviets did pretty much the same thing with Cosmo
only she wounded up being bombarded with cosmic
rays which gave her her powers and she wound up
on nowhere as part of the collector's collection
she speaks using the voice box Tech which is also
from the comics they bring back Howard Duck who
doesn't really have that much of a speaking role
but there's another Cameo from Lloyd Kaufman's
ravagers character he cameo in the previous
Guardians movies in real life James Gunn's first
job in Hollywood when he was young was working at
troma films for Lloyd coppin who served as like
an early mentor to him the broker is back from
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie apparently
he's living on nowhere now they also reveal that
they can actually fly nowhere around like a giant
ship it has thrusters and they've added weapons
to it in the eye socket because it probably cost
them a fortune to fix nowhere up and just keep it
running because they destroyed so many times I'm
assuming they just continue to sell off all the
celestial DNA that they've continued to mine that
you saw during the first movie that stuff will be
worth a fortune they reveal High evolutionary
throws nebula Drax and mantis to a bunch of
Obelisk creatures like the one in the second movie
and mantis winds up making friends with them using
her powers at the end of the movie she even leaves
nowhere with them as if they become her pets
Drax also reveals that he can speak filibella's
language they don't explain why he can do that I
think part of what's going on with his character
they kind of imply this during the movie James
Glenn's trying to say that he's neurodiversion
so his brain just processes things a little
differently and it comes off as him being autistic
but it allows him to understand this weird foreign
language like it's no big deal High evolutionary
releases his hell spawn which are basically just
like his failed Creations that he's turned into
weapons like his support Army when they attack
nowhere Cracklin has a vision of yondu giving
him a call to action like a little pep talk and
he uses his Fin and arrow finally correctly along
with Cosmo defeats most of the others calling her
a good doggo before she uses her telekinesis to
smash one of them Peter Quill cues up the Beastie
Boys No Sleep till Brooklyn song is they have
their Epic version of a daredevil style hallway
fight scene probably the best hallway fight
scene that they've done in any of the Marvel
movies so far we'll see if they top that in
any of the future ones expecting to see a lot
of really cool hallway fight scenes in the future
of Daredevil and the MCU they wind up rescuing all
the kids all the animals that were left there and
Groot rescues Adam Warlock winning him over to the
team after which he rescues Peter Quill there
was a super quick James Gunn Cameo during this
part of the movie too he actually did the voice
for this fleshy looking lump of alien that they
rescued that mantis freaks out when she sees oh I
wasn't yelling at you I was yelling at something
behind you they have that moment where rocket
actually finds out that he is a real raccoon
and uses his original key card to rescue all of
his descendants like his other relative raccoons
here that are still regular raccoons then all the
Guardians of the Galaxy defeat High evolutionary
revealing his messed up face which is a comic book
reference in the comics he has that red looking
face like he doesn't have an actual face because
he's messed it up so badly with all the upgrades
and experiences for formed on himself in the MCU
obviously it was rocket just clawing his face off
and if it wasn't clear rocket actually leaves him
alive at the end of the movie so potentially even
though his ship blew up it's possible to survive
like his a comic book movie so if you don't see
a body they probably survived when they go back
and things chill out Peter Quill says goodbye to
Gamora they don't wind up together but he finally
makes peace with her original death and they
become friends like he's friends with this version
of the character Zoe Saldana also said that this
was her last Marvel movie ever but we'll see about
that like don't hold your breath Dave Batista also
said the same thing too Peter Quill decides to go
back to Earth and spend time with his grandfather
after finally making peace with his mother's
death mantis also takes a break from the team
to just explore the Galaxy on her own Drax agrees
to take care of all the children that they rescued
like be a father to them nebula also becomes
administrator of nowhere rocket becomes captain
of the new Guardians team and Groot finally says
that full sentence I love you guys blowing all
their minds might theater went crazy too like oh
my God he's actually talking then paying off the
beginning of the movie Peter Quill leaves rocket
his Zune with a note written on his Alf TV show
stationary more 80s stuff said that he's kept in
his backpack they have a dance-off celebration
which is another reference to the dance off
from the first movie Peter Quill arrives at
his grandfather's house on earth the woman that
answers the doors the person that he remarried to
while he was gone and this is the first time
that he's seen his grandfather since he left
in the 80s their two post-credit scenes the first
post-credits scene reveals the brand new Guardians
of the Galaxy Team Rocket leading the team Groot
who's evolved again into like the gigachad version
of himself he looks more like King Groot from the
comics and the games with a big crown on his head
craglin who's finally gotten good at using yandu's
fin in his Arrow weapon then Cosmo the space dog
who we saw working with the team in the holiday
special in the totally new members replacing the
ones who also left are Adam Warlock in the comics
he became a member of the Guardians of the Galaxy
team during annihilation and then later in the
comics he's continuing his quest to understand
reality people morality just in general kind
of like Vision did after Avengers Age of Ultron
the next new member is philavel who's kind of
like the new version of Quasar from the comics
or will become Quasar in the future as far as I
can tell she doesn't have the quantum bands yet
so I think that'll be like some future story that
they can tell in other Marvel movies the last new
member of the new Guardians roster is blurp who's
another one of the high evolutionary's Creations
they rescue there's been a bunch of jokes
about him and all the trailers too and during
the post-credits scene the new Guardians team is
on a planet getting ready to protect a group of
townspeople from an invading Army of animals but
they're sitting around casually just joking with
each other about who their favorite music bands
are Phyla-Vell says her favorites are Britney Spears
and corn which are like two diametrically opposite
tones of bands like completely different Cracklin
says his favorite music is the man Garth Brooks
the country singer he really likes the classics
Cosmos says that she's never heard a bad song from
the car Carpenters but Adam warlock's favorite
music band is Adrian Ballou who was a guitarist
who ended up working with King Crimson who go
back to the 60s they're like a Prague rock group
in Rocket says his favorite song is actually huge
Easter egg from the original come and get your
love Redbone song at the very beginning of the
first Guardians of the Galaxy movie he says this
one's kind of special then cues up the song to
play on star-lord's Zune which he gave to Rocket
when he left the team to go back to Earth they
joke about who's going to be the one to defeat the
invading Army for the town like oh no I'll do it
I'll do it like it's no big deal kraglan says
he'll do it by himself just because they treat
it like it's not a big deal Rocket says they
should all do it together just so that it goes
faster and then he bumps Groot who's been lying
down taking a nap he rolls over and is super huge
like I said the gigachad version of Groot now and
as they start running towards the army of animals
the music swells up come and get your love and it
slams to credits with the song playing probably
not coming back till Avengers 5 King Dynasty or
Avengers 6 Secret Wars after that they probably
won't do Guardian into the Galaxy Forge the
movie because Disney said they're not doing
fourth sequels anymore for any of these movies but
the team will just keep crossing over with other
space-based movies the second post-credits scene
is a funny scene of Star-Lord who's gone back to
Earth now to live with his grandfather who he
saw in the first movie and in the actual scene
he's just jokingly talking to his grandfather
about Kevin Bacon being super weird and Casual
everyday problems like mowing the lawn very
mundane regular human problems and it's meant
to be a sign that he's finally found some peace
and doesn't have any Universe ending threats that
he's worried about at the current moment his
grandfather is reading the newspaper which has
the headline about Kevin Bacon being abducted by
aliens which is another holiday special reference
but a lot of people also think because secret
invasion is coming up and the whole idea that
it's all about alien infiltration the school's
infiltrating and taking over Earth's culture that
could be a reference to secret Invasion if you
spotted any other Easter eggs or references in
the movie that I didn't mention in this video
or my post credit scene video just write down
below in the comments there's a thousand things
that you could watch this movie 10 more times and
still find brand new stuff and I will do more
bonus videos this weekend so there's anything
that you really want me to do a video about let
me know in the comments congratulations to the
giveaway winner from that last big Guardians
video Vernal Thoughts please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get your contact
details everyone click here for my Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 post credit scene video and click
here for my brand new secret Invasion trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe and I'll see you guys in the next one